all of a sudden they say to me Robin hey
your wife's here with Jon Bon Jovi and
Dorothea Dorothea of course John's wife
I said wow this is like I'm creating a
scene it's becoming a scene look there's
a famous guy Jon Bon Jovi look at this
guy all full of himself Big Shot look at
him look at my wife and look at Dorothea
how how honored and blessed I am
Dorothea we've never had her on the show
before I don't think look at you look at
you too I can't believe it it's more
look at you I can't believe you're here
nice studio right isn't that
unbelievable you know uh people talk
about John never mind John Dorothea is
really who I'm most interested in we
just had our 34th anniversary hour
congratulations what what did John do
for your 34th anniversary what was it
besides of course making love to you
that night did John take you in his arms
and bring you to the bedroom on that
night always Howard Dorothy it did say
to me John insists on me making love to
Jon Bon Jovi song
what is your favorite I told you that
is very true
John what is your favorite song of yours
to make love to you know I usually try
to put on the early
um outfits to go with the early yeah
John to me was always music obsessed at
least that's the image I get yes when
you were in high school with him we you
and the girls always like oh there's
that guy the singer in the band I knew
he played in a band but we weren't all
like titillated by it but I was he the
cutest guy in the high school 100 he was
100 the cutest guy in the high school
when John sat next to you in History
Class you're like Jesus there's a guy
I'll go out with you absolutely did he
have the whole Bon Jovi look at that
point he did oh he had the whole thing
yeah he was a rock star
look at you wow did you guys know Bruce
back then all the way back then you did
yeah he would come to the clubs and be
in the audience yeah everybody would see
Bruce yeah really I didn't know you went
back that far with him yeah first time
um he jumped on stage with me I was 16
or 17 years old wow I didn't know that
1979 so that makes me what 17. John
you've been playing since you were 16
years old so again getting back to
Dorothea the way to seduce Dorothy yeah
yeah because to me Dorothy is a tough
customer put up with any she's
a black belt and karate you should kick
your ass if you you know to me I would
have said to Dorothea listen I want you
to come see me play at a bar and that
was seal the deal yes I was in my first
original band where I was not the the
the it wasn't my band right I was a
singer in someone else's band called the
rest but we skipped our prom and I was
opening for South Side uh at the
Freehold Raceway you opened up for
Southside Johnny while you were in high
school in high school I remember we went
to the diner after to the show and all
the kids were in their prom outfits and
we were coming in for a burger and blue
jeans and t-shirts having just played to
10 000 people opening for John John do
you know
um why I skipped my high school prom
tell me why I didn't open for South Side
Johnny because no one wanted to go with
it there's no point
the Superstar you see in front of you
now didn't exist took a long time to
mold this Personality yeah wow so uh so
you take Dorothea to a gig yeah I just
remember being impressed that you could
sing was he good he was very good he was
really good you knew right away yeah
well you like her I better marry this
guy yeah that's what I thought
Dorothy I would think more like I better
not marry this guy because he's not
going to make a living he's going to be
a singer well that was I know that was
everybody's response like and I remember
somebody told me a story that I said
well my boyfriend's gonna be a rock star
and they were like good luck with that
good luck eating
oh